by the summer of 2021 it was Apparent
from Provincetown Massachusetts and
other instances that you would get
people who were vaccinated were still
able to catch the virus and transmit the
virus that means all the mandates that
happened in the fall which was when
Biden pushed the mandates were medically
unethical because you cannot compel an
intervention on a third party if it
provides sorry you cannot compel a
medical invention on somebody unless
there is a benefit to third parties but
by the fall of 2021 we knew that that
wasn't the case now I want to point out
we could have made Pfizer answer the
question in the randomized trial Pfizer
ran in 2020 we could have asked them to
swab people randomly and their
households randomly and we would have
had an estimate of transmission but over
and over again you'll see that to some
degree both administrations give the
companies the benefit of the doubt the
easiest path forward